well folks it's finally happened six
months ago riot announced they would be
investigating tsm founder and owner
reggie for workplace misconduct over his
alleged verbal abuse and bullying of tsm
staff and players the highly anticipated
results of this investigation have
finally been released let's take a look
okay so by now most of you watching this
will already know the story but to
understand just exactly what these
investigation results actually mean
let's quickly run back over the last
eight months or so in november 2021
doublelift a retired league pro and
former tsm player accused tsm's owner
reggie of being a bully who made players
cry he's like a bully who gets away with
being a bad person
because he's powerful because people are
afraid to stand up to him and that's
what i'm sick of so i would just say
that he made a lot of players cry you
would be very [__] surprised
at how many of maybe your favorite
familiar faces in lcs
legit mental breakdown because of how
badly
they've been getting berated how badly
they were just getting verbally
assaulted this was definitely the most
high profile and public accusation made
up to that point but there had been
allegations of similar behavior dating
way back to the inception of tsm as an
org in january this year wyatt shared
their investigation into the claims
these included reports from former tsm
staff that they had allegedly been
subject to quote mental abuse by reggie
and that they've been quote dominated by
a culture of fear wyatt also said wright
had informed them they've begun an
independent investigation into the
claims through the law firm oh melvani
and myers at this time tsm also said
they'd be conducting their own
investigation as well through a separate
law firm we got the results of that at
the end of may reggie himself shared the
results of the report on twitter which
included the summary of the law firm
gutierrez and marca to put it simply the
investigation found no unlawful conduct
from reggie no witnesses reported
derogatory comments that all female
interviewees did not feel they were
marginalized and that they found no
cases of sexual harassment or gender
discrimination however after
interviewing 31 current and former tsm
staff they found that reggie exhibited
an aggressive and harsh tone when
providing feedback to employees three
interviewees also reported hearing
reggie call employees stupid trash or
worthless and six characterize reddy's
conduct as creating a culture of fear at
tsm they also gave reggie a list of
remedial recommendations moving forward
which reggie agreed to implement these
include him working with an executive
coach in order to improve his
communication as well as a three-month
evaluation of the company's culture and
the implementation of an anonymous
hotline in the workplace that in a
pretty large nutshell is everything that
happened before this week the missing
pieces of course were the results of
riot's own investigation and that's what
we got yesterday it began by summarizing
much of what we've discussed so far in
this video including tsm's investigation
and the initial claims by doublelift
although he was not mentioned by name
riot then moved into the scope of their
investigation and whether the team
participation agreement or tpa for short
was broken by reggie referred to by his
surname here as din they sought to
answer four questions how serious and
pervasive were the actions underlying
the reports of din's treatment of and
behavior towards tsm players and staff
did din make disparaging or harassing
comments related to the race national
origin sexual orientation or any other
protected class of any individual or
group or take actions or make comments
that would create an inference that din
discriminated against sexually harassed
or unlawfully harassed anyone connected
with tsm and were their credible reports
of other actions by din including
physical violence that would give rise
to a violation of the tpa or rules they
added that they were aware of the
allegations made against tsm that they
had misclassified certain workers as
contractors instead of full-time
employees this is a red line in labor
laws because it relates to how workers
are paid what benefits they receive and
what legal rights they have wright said
these questions were outside the scope
of their investigation and that they
would only revisit them if there was a
court ruling or an admission of
wrongdoing moving on to the
investigation process riot said they
spoke to 14 individuals including reggie
interviewees were selected based on
their complaints to the players
association or by the mention of their
names in other interviews one
interesting section discussed how riot
conducted a small number of their
interviews alongside tsm's own
investigation for in their words the
sake of efficiency they said individuals
were given an additional opportunity to
speak to riots separately as well
without tsm's investigator in the room
to ensure they could speak in a quote
open and candid way right we're keen to
stress here as well that they didn't
give tsm visibility on their
investigation or give them a list of
individuals they planned to speak to
they also said they did not share notes
or conclusions and did not collaborate
with tsm on their investigation or
announcement next up came the findings
riot state that they believed there was
a quote pattern and practice of
disparaging and bullying behavior
exhibited by din this included verbally
abusing pro players and tsm staff
members and communicating in a demeaning
and belittling manner they said that
almost all their witnesses agreed that
reggie's outburst and abuse were related
to staff performance and none of them
attributed this behavior to be related
to an individual's age sex race gender
sexual orientation or sexual identity
etc before giving their ruling riot said
it had taken into account an incident
from february 2021 on twitter where
reggie told then cloud9 support vulcan
that quote if every lcs team left the
lcs you'll be out of a job buddy and
probably be paid minimum reggie would
subsequently find five thousand dollars
for this and said he'd apologize to
vulcan riot found reggie had breached
two of their rules the first on
profanity and hate speech and the second
on the forbidding of harassment and then
finally we have the ruling buckle up for
this riot said reggie also broke a tsa
rule in which teams agreed to quote
manage and operate the team in a
professional manner in accordance with
the highest standards in the esports
industry end quote normally riot uses
their lcs penalty index for rulings but
states they have deviated from it for
this ruling because they have no basis
upon which to determine how many
instances of abuse and harassing conduct
took place they have fined tsm 75 000
which represents three times the usual
fine to reflect the lengthy multi-year
pattern they believe existed the money
will go to anti-bullying or mental
health charity selected by the players
association tsm is required to provide
evidence within 60 days that ready has
completed sensitivity and executive
training which must be provided by a
third party the third party and their
qualifications must be submitted to riot
for approval beforehand they added that
they hope this will teach reggie to find
more constructive ways of providing
feedback finally reggie is to be put on
probation for the next two years during
this time if reggie has found to have
violated their rules they will enforce
quote severely enhanced penalties wright
will also be instating an independent
monitor to act as a tip line through
which tsm employees can anonymously
report any abusive conduct from reggie
the monitor will also check in with
current esm players for reports of any
rule violations tsm will also be
required to explain the existence and
purpose of the tip line to not only
their current players and staff but also
to any new hires brought into the
company okay well
there it is the long anticipated ruling
and as you might expect there were a lot
of reactions from the community some
felt this was too lenient of a
punishment when compared to riot rulings
in the past or felt that a 75 000
penalty for tsm and sensitivity training
did not amount to enough of a punishment
ryan fairchild of the lcs players
association said that the biggest part
of the punishment are the two years of
probation an anonymous tip line being
set up for tsm employees and staff
others echoed this sentiment that the
probation or tip line will help to
protect individuals in the future you
will compete complete sensitivity
training and executive training
and he is on probation for the next two
years across the riot ecosystem
and an independent monitor is being
appointed to operate a tip line and
follow through with regular check-ins
with tsm league of legends players
deserve deserved
oh yeah
i mean
doesn't mean much still but at least
it's something you know it's better than
nothing doublelift who arguably brought
all of this into the spotlight last
november had a lot to say about this on
stream particularly about riot
conducting some of their interviews
alongside tsm's investigator a small
number of interviews with current taste
of employees were conducted jointly
tsm's independent investigator there
what the [__]
if you are a sus if you're a sus of
tsm's independent investigator and
they're conducting it jointly with that
person and riots investigator there of
course that's going to make them feel a
little bit more like way more nervous
and tight-lipped about the situation
that is weird yeah lena's saying that um
we heard from
some of the people who worked there and
were contacted by that investigator
tsm's independent investigator didn't
identify himself as that and uh thought
that they were talking to riot that
whole time
like he identified himself essentially
as like
or she identified herself
as working with riot when it was
actually
tsm's independent investigator
it's just
so
crazy he also took note of the fact that
tsm will have to inform any new
employees for the next two years of
reggie's probation and the anonymous tip
line how [__] humiliating is that
holy sh
that is crazy
you sign up to join tsm and you get a
sheet that says yo
your ceo is a known [__] and terrible
person
here's a tip line in case you have any
sus interactions with him um totally
anonymous he's on probation that is so
insanely humiliating
holy [__]
so where do we stand now well for a long
time it felt like this story might come
to a close with the publication of
riot's investigation results but after
reading the conditions of reddy's
probation and the monitoring that will
continue for the next two years it still
feels like an ongoing situation the 75
is a slap on the wrist the sensitivity
training might be wishful thinking but
the fact that riot will be checking in
with tsm's players and that employees
will be able to whistleblow any abusive
behavior that's pretty huge will it
remedy the bullying behavior that riot
says reggie has exhibited in the past
who knows in many ways this is uncharted
territory we've never seen a league org
have riot monitoring them as hard as
we're about to see with reggie and tsm
over the next two years during this time
no news is likely good news but if
another chapter unfolds in this story
we'll be sure to let you know
you